Ciao, mi chiamo Katy Beslado
e sono la direttrice della strategia IBM Quantum
e della ricerca applicata. Sono qui per sfatare
il maggior numero possibile di miti sul quantum computing
in sessanta secondi.
I computer quantistici sono assolutamente reali
e abbiamo dispositivi sul cloud IBM a cui chiunque può accedere.
Sì, ma solo per certe cose in cui sono davvero bravi,
come la matematica super complicata su cui si basa l'universo,
ma se vuoi fare fogli di calcolo o email, usa
il tuo PC.
Sì, teoricamente, ma non
presto: nessuno costruisce ancora computer abbastanza potenti da farlo,
ma per il futuro prevedibile siamo sulla buona strada
e quando ci arriveremo, cambieremo il modo in cui proteggiamo
le informazioni.
Completamente falso. I computer quantistici
sono fondamentalmente diversi
e usano le leggi della natura per elaborare le informazioni.
L'IA di oggi gira su classici e collaudati dispositivi classici,
ma crediamo che collaboreranno in futuro.
Non è vero: abbiamo un enorme ecosistema
di startup, università, laboratori nazionali e partner industriali che
usano i nostri dispositivi ogni giorno.
No, il quantum-inspired esiste da
molto tempo e gira su dispositivi classici: non
manterrà mai la promessa del quantum computing.
Se vuoi il quantum computing vero, devi farlo con veri computer quantistici.
computers